hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda level 455 walkthrough
with some tips this is a pain level I
had to play it several times to beat it
again and a lot of people have been
asking about it so I'm gonna add some
tips that I figured out during this
process so I'm gonna go ahead and get
started there's several things that make
this level hard small space is the is
the big thing in the beginning and when
I first started I was just trying to get
rid of these licorice links first but I
realized that making combos in the
middle is actually the most important
thing that gets things cleared out the
fastest
it'll get those bottles popped faster so
that you can actually make make the soda
rise and that's where you can you know
you can start getting fish like crazy
and that'll really speed things up so
first things first
just look trying to get like a you know
you want to get either you know like a
collar bomb combo or a strike fuss of
raft which is what I got here and
eventually we'll get these bottles to
come up and what else happens is when
you make a big bigger one like that you
know you get some of the soda exposed at
the bottom so you might be able to get a
couple random fish to come up I used
sprinkle shown on the green there
because it cleared out the bottom half
and we got a cop a couple color bomb
matches here but you know the this first
part is it's tough when you can't get a
big combo and if you can't get out of
here with you know like about you know
somewhere around 20 moves left because a
lot of times you get stuck in the second
half so you know when you have a bad
start
it'll really give you trouble and one
thing that's great about making the the
colorbond plus the strike match there is
that it actually gets the bear all the
way to the end so he's ready to go and
it also gave a sprinkle shell loaded up
and ready to go - so we got these two
bottles out as fast as I can and then
I'm gonna just try to make some matches
inside the the inside the soda so that I
can get as many fish as possible because
you can see how much ice is up there
it's it's a real pain I'm sure you know
if you played it before wrapped candies
are really great in this level because
they go off in the the green soda twice
so you get a blast of fish and then a
second pasta fish so you always want to
try to make those if you can
regular fish aren't as good because they
won't they won't do much but a lot of
times when you're making matches you're
gonna make fish anyways because you get
four from the green soda you know you
get four to come out so that went really
good we got through that we cleared the
middle out pretty fast
can't complain there now we want to look
for stuff like obviously color bombs
that we could combo but we want to make
wraps and we want to look and maybe make
some striped candies that we can match
with fish because they'll take out that
whole top row they won't I mean they
won't clear it but they'll go across it
and hit all of them at once which is
awesome I think here you know we want to
just take out one of the colors well we
could have done that but as you can see
the double the double wrapped is is
crazy good because it shoots off a big
area twice it shoots off of a five by
five square that's a lot of fish and
that pretty much set everything up for
us up the top we can use the sprinkle
shell to get a free move
which will clear out a lot of things and
now we're just really like one or two
matches away from finishing off we got
four coils and that'll clear it out and
we get past it
you know a lot of times that second room
won't go so smoothly and you know just
hang in there the the things you want to
look for is you want to clear you want
to get the bottles popped in the middle
so you can make more soda and you want
to just keep making matches on the soda
and make them as efficient as possible
so you get as many like green fish women
as you can
it's a tough level it took me quite a
few tries to make this video so like I
said just hang in there and go for you
know take a break if you need to if you
get too frustrated and hopefully you'll
get it soon I hope this helped the
rewind a little bit and watch right when
I got into the second room and that
you'll see how I kind of made those
choices to help get things started
if you have any questions go ahead and
leave them in the comments please like
this video and subscribe to our channel
so that we can you know you'll find us
when you need another commentary video
of a tip soon and we'll be back to see
you when the next episode comes out
thanks